[Music]
your ex demi lovato how do you feel
about her performance oh it's great
she's she's a hero man I'm excited that
she's there and for this historic moment
for young people ET was on the ground
with clear eyes Karami brown
he's an alum of parkland Florida's
Marjory Stoneman Douglas High School and
marched with the Human Rights Campaign
what was it like for you looking out at
that crowd it just let me know how much
people do care not cut you but each
other in New York City Paul McCartney
marched in memory of John Lennon one of
my best friends was killed in gun
violence right around here
so it's important to me in LA amy
schumer addressed the large crowd I
stand with you backstage she posed with
students who spoke on behalf of moms
demand action Reese Witherspoon is on
the organization's creative council and
attended the March with her big little
eyes co-star lord Dern the marchers were
also on the minds of stars like Kristen
Bell who attended the Nickelodeon Kids
Choice Awards later that day honestly
gets me choked up because I think this
is the generation we've been waiting for
stranger think star Millie Bobby Brown
honored the 17 parkland victims in both
her speech and fashion I felt that it
needed to be said not only do i verbally
say it but i can physically wear
something that represents them
so many people getting involved I love
the picture cuff Kanye and Northwest
share was also busy on social media it's
great to see everybody involved using
their voice to make a difference
[Applause]
[Music]